there's something holding you back even
if it's dear to you
you have to let it go you seriously have
to let it go
because there isn't anything more
important than progressing forward
and and cheap sympathy cheap empathy
cheap
nostalgia none of that is sufficient
none of that will
work because the consequences of not
putting things together
immediately are dire and there's no time
to wait
god only knows what will happen to you
if you put your house in order
certainly things that you do not
currently regard as possible
will happen and the more you put your
house in order the more
things that you regard as impossible
will happen
and it might be the case that if you put
your house together sufficiently
things that were of miraculous
impossibility would happen to you
well and there's no way of knowing until
you try it
but there's no way of being sure that
it's not the case unless you do and
my experience has been that
i don't mean just personally i mean that
the world is a remarkable and mysterious
place
and the relationship between the nature
and structure of the world and your
actions is
indeterminate they may be more tightly
related than you think
the in the utility of rekindling
the aims of your highest values when you
come to the end of an epoch in your life
when you have to take stock again right
you take stock of yourself that's really
what that phrase means to take stock is
to take stock of yourself and to decide
okay well
what should move forward in time with me
and what should be let go as if it's
dead wood
and the more dead wood that you let go
of and burn off when you have the
opportunity the less it accretes around
you
as you elevate your aim
you create a judge at the same time
right because
the new ideal which is an ideal you even
if it's just
an ideal position that you might occupy
even if it's still conceptualized in
that concrete
way that becomes a judge because it's
above you
right and then you're you're terrified
of it maybe
that's why you might be afraid when you
go start a new job right because you're
this thing is above you and you're
terrified of it and it judges you
and that's useful because the judge
that you're creating by formulating the
ideal tells you
what's useless about yourself and then
you can dispense with it
and you want to keep doing that and then
every time you make a judge that's more
elevated then there's more useless you
that has to be dispensed with you don't
have to pick an external ideal you can
pick an ideal that
fulfills the role of ideal for you you
can say okay well
if things could be set up for me the way
i need them to be and if i could be who
i needed to
be what would that look like and you can
figure that out for yourself and then
instantly you have a judge and i also
think that's part of the reason people
don't do it
right why don't why don't people look up
and move ahead
and the answer is well you know you
start formulating an ideal you formulate
a judge it's pretty easy to feel
intimidated in the face of your own
ideal
that's what happens to cain versus abel
for example then it's really easy to
destroy the ideal instead of to try to
pursue it because
then you get rid of the judge but it's
way better
lower the damn judge if it's too much
like if your current ambition is
crushing you
you know then maybe you're playing the
tyrant to yourself and you should
tap down your ambitions not get rid of
them by any stretch of the imagination
but at least put them more
reasonably within your grasp you don't
have to leap from point one to point
fifty in one leap right
you can do it incrementally where do i
wanna be more comfortable
do i wanna be more comfortable with that
which i already know and so that would
be
the circumscribed territory that you've
already mastered or do i want to be
comfortable
with all those things i don't know and
then
the right answer is that you should want
to be comfortable with all those things
that you don't know because
there's a bloody lot of things that you
don't know and if you can be a sojourner
among what you don't know
well then you're so protected because
well you're going to go lots of places
where you don't know and you're going to
be able to manage it so you want to be
you want to be that person that can act
where they don't know
you see this with antisocial kids it's a
very tragic thing to see because if
you're an antisocial child by the time
you're about four
you're very hostile and distrustful to
people and so you're like a growling
puppy and if you're a growling puppy you
tend not to get petted you're more
likely to get kicked
and if you're a growling puppy and you
get kicked then you have even more
reason to growl
and that's sort of the story of
antisocial kids if they're not
well socialized by the time they're four
and they're more on the aggressive side
then they alienate themselves from the
community and all they get is rejection
well and then they look at the rejection
and they think
well hell with humanity you know
and no wonder they think that but but
the part of the catastrophe is is that
they get what they evoke and i'm not
saying it's their fault
precisely but it doesn't matter that's
still what happens and so you might ask
yourself
if you're not getting from people what
you need
there is some possibility that you're
not approaching especially if this
happens to you repeatedly across
people and this is a virtual certainty
if it happens to you repeatedly across
people especially
if you have the same bad experience with
people it's not them it's you
i would say three is the limit if
something happens to you once
you write it off if it happens to you
twice it's like
you open your eyes but you write it off
but if it happens to you three times
it's probably you or it's the rest of
the world
better it's you because you're not going
to change the rest of the world
and if you don't want it you're not
going to get it because you're scattered
but if you do want it and you make the
proper sacrifices then
god only knows what might happen and
that's a see one of the things i really
like about the existential
philosophers is their emphasis on
personal responsibility you know that
many of them had an emphasis
on the role that people had in
shaping their own destiny the exit for
the existentialists and i think this was
a consequence of
the religious substructure of of
philosophical thinking
it was self-evident that life was tragic
and
and bitter but and then fair enough but
that isn't where it ended
the the next issue was well there are
better in ways
better and worse ways of dealing with
that and the better way of dealing with
the fact that life is tragic
and better is to posit
the self you could be and live
authentically in relationship to that
no one can take the adventure of life
away from you that
that's they can't do it with good advice
for example
because no one can demonstrate to you
that if you straighten yourself
out and aim at what you want and make
the proper sacrifices
that your life will turn out in the
manner that you might want it to turn
out
it isn't in anyone else's purview to
make that judgment the only person that
can
possibly figure that out is you it's
something that can't be stolen from you
i would say it's your destiny it's a
destiny that cannot be stolen from you
and you can forego it you can say well
i'm not willing to put in the effort
because what if i fail well first of all
if you don't put in the effort
you will fail because life is hard
and it takes everything out of you to do
it properly
if the proper order of being is violated
then that's something like the balance
between chaos
and order say if the proper balance of
being is
violated then all hell will break loose
and
one of the things i can tell you from
reading a very
from reading a very comprehensive set of
myths from around the world
is that that's a conclusion that human
beings have come to
everywhere stay on the god damn path
and be careful because if you start to
mess around
and you deviate especially if you know
that you're deviating
things are not going to go well for you
and that idea is everywhere and i think
it's
right i think the idea is right because
there aren't that many ways of doing
things right and there's a lot of ways
of doing things wrong
and if you do things wrong the
consequences of doing them wrong can be
truly catastrophic
he said that a human being is not only
responsible for everything they do but
for everything that everyone else does
now you know that's crazy and he was an
epileptic and a mystic and that's a
crazy thing to say
but it's also there's something about it
that's true because if you were better
the people around you would be less
worse than they are
and if you were good enough you don't
know how much better the people around
you would be
the sexual thing here is something more
like the absolute danger of immediate
gratification
sexual included outside the constraints
of any civilized
structure whatsoever there's no excuse
whatsoever for not getting at
what it is that you should be doing and
i think
there's something else that's going on
here especially in the new testament
stories which is even made
maybe worse which is it's absolutely
reprehensible
to justify your inaction with a
catastrophe that extracts
mercy from other people right there's a
tricky
tricky game that's going well of course
i can't do that look at the terrible
thing that's just happened to me it's a
okay i understand you're absolved of any
necessity to move forward because of
your
current catastrophe it's like well
actually you're not
and it's rather rude of you to use it as
an excuse and it's certainly
counterproductive
are you in a place that's so bad that
you should leave and if you are in a
place
that's so bad that you should leave then
the time to leave is now
because there's no time to waste